Just like out cheeses, if we have just one copy of the T allele, or in this case
the plus sign allele, it's like our cheddar. And
it's going to be strong enough to show the
phenotype. So obviously the homozygous condition will show the
lactose tolerance, but so will the heterozygous condition. Only
one allele is all you need to actually be
able to digest some lactose. For the mozzarella flavor Or
the C allele in this case, the minus minus, needs to be in
homozygous condition before you see the trait
of lactose intolerance show up. Very briefly
note the fact that one homozygous and one heterozygous scenario gives you the
same phenotype. Whereas the other homozygous genotype,
or combination, gives you the other phenotype.